guys we did it how do they go to another
wedding hey guys come on mouth two more
all right
and then wedding season is over over Oh
got a phone call hey cousin Roberto
oh what a season oh hey look at that
your USA but guess what I'm getting
married you're getting married that's
awesome congratulations I'm so happy for
you you want to come to my wedding love
you have to be there uh yeah of course
I'll come to your way Justin how many
gay friends do we have
major musical theater they'll be a
pre-wedding the reception the second
reception how many celebrations are you
having
let's double the wedding so we're
waiting how many different cities for
three more including Ohio for his family
wait five more than for mine cooking
degree be there it's not over
I'm gonna stick out like a straight
white male on a gay man's wedding we
have to go to 47 weddings in the next
two months
oh no it's 48 not only are you guys
invited to the wedding
coincidence I want you to be my bride to
man I'm gonna be a bridesmaid and double
the wedding's double the wedding I
cannot take a gay man's bachelor party
the Macarena child's led to these people
it's all about the YMCA girl I only seek
a suit which way is east
I'm gonna go broke oh all right so he
took care of the present good no no this
is Sunbeam Zack you went to Target what
if Synovus too expensive
we're friends hell death do us part
you
Oh oh my god it's just her neighbor
Christian what's up oh nothing
where you guys headed so fancy it's
going to a wedding so our friends and
Nathaniel and Steve I'm sorry you say
Nathan and it sounded like you said
Steve I mean that I know would be a
unnatural right